here's five things you can do to get  anyone to understand what you're trying  to tell the first is you take out  adverbs so when people say really very  extremely it actually adds words and  makes it more confusing the second thing  is speaking the passive tone a business  is valued by instead of saying that you  say we value a business this way so it  goes from passive to active voice the  third way is by using shorter words and  shorter sentences instead of having  colons and commas just put the period  there and start the next sentence the  fourth thing is using shorter and  smaller words people have to understand  what you're actually saying and the last  thing is you want to use vocabulary that  everyone understands so rather than  saying are multiple different sources i  might say lots of stuff